okay I've got some clips to play for you
today from a recent interview that
right-winger ben shapiro did on Joe
Rogan's podcast we could do 30 minutes
on all of the caveats about Joe Rogan
and Ben Shapiro we can talk about Joe
Rogan effectively according to some
serving as a gateway to the alt-right we
can talk about the ways in which ben
shapiro
appears to be very informed and
convincing but often says things that
don't make sense I've said before if you
listen really closely to ben shapiro you
will often realize that even though he's
speaking confidently and he's speaking
quickly that what he's saying is
actually not making that much sense and
i have a couple of really funny examples
of that and Joe Rogan I don't even know
that Joe Rogan realized how much he
exposed ben shapiro in the clips that
i'm going to play for you today so to
set it up this gets to a portion of the
interview between ben shapiro and joe
rogan where i guess i would say it's
about ben shapiro religious beliefs and
Joe Rogan's asking questions about Ben
Shapiro's Orthodox Judaism and mostly
they're talking about homosexuality
which I'm going to get to a little bit
later in the clip but Joe and Ben sort
of agree that there are some historical
reasons why things became Commandments
in the Old Testament for example they
agree that there are some historical
realities at the time which explained to
us like for example the Bible mentions
man shall not lie with another man or
whatever the phrase is I don't even care
but the the line that's pointed to that
people point to is saying homosexuality
is bad that wasn't in the Bible because
the people who wrote the Bible thought
in a thousand years maybe there will be
gay people it was there because they saw
gay people at the time and they decided
we're gonna put something in the Bible
about it okay the the the example
doesn't really matter but the idea is
the Bible reflects things that were
happening at the time so Joe Rogan
brings up a sort of naturalistic
explanation for why eating pork is not
Oh
in Judaism it's also not okay in Islam
the same analysis would sort of apply
related to the cooking temperature of
pork and bacteria and whatever you'll
hear it in a second and ben shapiro says
very clearly he doesn't like
naturalistic explanations for this stuff
check it out and pay really close
attention here to what ben shapiro says
like the very reason to have a
commandment is because certain people in
your community are behaving in a
particular way presumably right there's
no commandment not to take your head and
shove it in a meat grinder well this is
also the argument against pork is
because they didn't understand
trichinosis they understand you have to
cook the meat to 145 degrees and pork
parasites which are very dangerous for
people so i'm not a huge fan of
naturalistic explanations for religion
so i think that's a good one though for
pork i mean i don't know like i think
you could make an argument maybe okay
ben shapiro
says very clearly he's against
naturalistic explanations for religion
meaning he doesn't like explaining
religious precepts with sort of
real-world justifications from nature
ben shapiro said very clearly he's
against that fine so then about 90
seconds go by okay this next clip is
from 90 seconds after what I just played
for you and ben shapiro gives a
naturalistic explanation for Moses
parting the Red Sea he just said he's
not into naturalistic explanations and
here he gives a naturalistic explanation
90 seconds later do you think it
resurrected no that's not that's not a
Jewish belief okay just one shot ya know
any miracles no not by Jesus they're
their ones the old women yeah you've got
Moses splitting the sea and all that
what do you think happen there what do I
think happened there yeah well I'll go
with my mana D and explanation that
there was a mean it says in the Bible
there was a strong east wind so there's
a naturalistic explanation for a
physical phenomenon that makes sense I
mean that's what Maimonides is
constantly trying to do is read nature
back into the Bible mmm yeah he says
it's the miracle of Moses parting the
Red Sea and he naturalistically explains
it
in the Red Sea area which is a very
common naturalistic explanation for the
parting of the Red Sea in the old
testament which he just said he's not in
favor of he's not in favor of those
types of explanations except all of a
sudden when he is and this reminds me of
naturalistic explanations for Noah's Ark
if you talk to some religious people
about Noah's Ark they'll say no you know
we've sort of identified where there
were floods at the time based on
geological records and here is how it
all could have worked so on and so forth
never explains how some of the species
need salt water and some need fresh
water and how did they get all of that
onto the ark for the time it had to be
there it doesn't explain how there are
carnivorous animals and if you only had
two of each species didn't any of them
get eaten did you start with more than
two and they were eaten down to two or
did carnivorous animals get fed some
kind of Soylent or vegan diet during
none of that stuff is explained but at
least the the specifics of the flood are
sometimes explained naturalistically
with Noah's Ark this is the same thing
here naturalistically explaining the
parting of the Red Sea after saying he
doesn't like naturalistic explanations
now I know some people will say David
hold on ben shapiro says
Maimonides gives that explanation it
doesn't matter ben shapiro said he's not
for naturalistic explanations of
religious stories or merrick or miracles
or phenomena and the 90 seconds later he
insta flips on himself and it was a
missed opportunity actually for Joe to
call him out on that so then they get
back to homosexuality and to Dave
Reubens marriage to his husband Dave
Rubin is a cultural critic and political
commentator who engages in the battle of
ideas where the free market allows the
best ideas to float to the top sort of
like fatten on milk or butter or
whatever anyway they get to Dave Reubens
marriage which Ben Shapiro has been
saying for a while how he would not go
to Dave's room Dave Reubens wedding or I
guess wouldn't have gone if they had
been friends at the time I don't know
that they knew each other at the time
but he'd still have Dave and his husband
over for dinner because going to the
wedding goes again
his religious beliefs but I guess having
them to dinner doesn't and Joe Rogan
just exposes the idiocy idiocy of it so
easily right and one of the things that
I the reason I keep coming back to the
governmental regulation point is because
my view is that if your view of
discipline is not my view discipline
good on you right like go do what you
want to do like I've never had a
conversation with Dave Rubin about about
him being a gay guy right but you did
say that you like wouldn't go to his
marriage right well I said right as a
religious person I can't say I can't
actively participate in something that I
consider to be a sin but I would go out
to dinner with Dave and his husband
anytime like my wife and I would do that
of course we'd have him over to our
house with his husband there's no you
don't find any contradiction between
your religious perspective and your
personal perspective in that regard that
you would though you wouldn't be there
for religious reasons but that you would
be there for personal reasons like if it
wasn't would you go to the after-party
like if you wouldn't go to the wedding
would you go to the after-party anything
that was a celebration of same-sex
marriage no wow so anything but like if
we go to the party no I mean there's a
barbecue the next day you know it's and
again like I'm not sure why I'm not a
good party person so I'm not sure why
anybody would want me at their party I
haven't been to a party with you but I
went to a dinner party with you that's
right we had a great time that was a
good time that's good that's a funny
picture man that is well don't know what
the [ __ ] to think about that picture we
had it's certainly true Eric and Jordan
so Joe Rogan's being sort of funny about
it
he's very prescient Lee exposing the
absurdity of what ben shapiro is saying
going out to dinner with a gay couple
who you recognize as a gay couple is
recognizing the idea that they are a
couple which his religion considers a
sin it's a very sort of mealy-mouthed
weird gray area to say well I wouldn't
go to the wedding ceremony because then
I would be endorsing something my
religion believes as a sin and I
wouldn't go to the wedding reception and
just have dinner because I would be
recognizing the sin but like a couple
days later I'd go to dinner with them as
a couple which of course is recognized
as a couple which his religion believes
is a sin but that would sort of be okay
in been Shapiro's mind and you know he
says he wouldn't go to anything that
celebrates same-sex marriage I hate to
break it to you but when you go out with
a couple who is married and it's a gay
couple you're effectively celebrating or
at minimum recognizing something that
your religion teaches you is a sin it is
the fence sitting that is so
mealy-mouthed
that I found just laughable here and
here Joe Rogan actually does a really
good job when he says what about the
reception what about a barbecue the day
after like at what point is going to
hang out with Dave Rubin and his husband
disconnected enough from the fact that
it's a gay couple that's married under
the law that you can sort of rationalize
it post facto in a way that feels okay
for what your religion teaches this is
why it's all nonsense and really nice
job by Joe Rogan in exposing it and by
the way ben shapiro is welcome on the
show anytime he's been on before think
at this point he probably yeah i think
he's too big for the david pakman show
at this point he's got bigger fish to
fry
but open invitation for him anytime
follow me on twitter at D Pakman follow
the show on Twitter at David Pakman show
I would love to hear from you about this
of course today's program was made
possible in part by better help.com
slash Pakman better help is an online
service that gives you access to your
own experienced fully licensed therapist
via phone video and text when you see a
therapist in person in their office it
can take three weeks on average before
you're able to get in for your first
appointment but with better help you're
matched with a therapist who fits your
needs within just 24 hours and you get
the same professional service and the
best part is that better help is less
expensive than seeing a therapist in
person as well plus you will have
totally unlimited access to the
therapist you can talk to them whenever
you want on your phone or computer and
because better help believes in what
they do they also have a full money-back
guarantee if you're not happy with the
service
you'll get a full refund no questions
asked all of their therapists go through
an extensive vetting process and are
required to have at least three years of
experience before joining better help so
you know you're getting someone who's
fully qualified to help you but if you
don't think that your therapist is a
good fit better help lets you switch to
someone new at any time if you've been
thinking about getting involved with
therapy you should really check out
better help just click the link
underneath this video